we've just had a bit of breaking news
and Sport and here's Gemma to tell us
all about it Gemma yes thank you Laura
well some huge breaking news from the
world of tennis Roger Federer has
announced he will retire from the sport
after next week's Laver cup the 41 year
old has struggled with injuries the past
three years and hasn't played since
Wimbledon last year Federer is regarded
as one of the greatest men's players of
all time winning 20 grand slam titles
which puts him third on the all-time
list behind Novak Djokovic and Rafael
Nadal he says he will no longer play in
Majors or on the ATP Tour effectively
ending an incredible career which has
spanned two decades his last event as I
mentioned will be in London at the Laver
cup which starts next Friday this is how
Federer announced his decision on social
media
as many of you know the past three years
have presented me with challenges in the
form of injuries and surgeries
I've worked hard to return to full
competitive form but I also know my
body's capacities and limits and its
message to me lately has been clear
I am 41 years old I've played more than
1 500 matches over 24 years tennis has
treated me more generously than I ever
would have dreamed and now I must
recognize when it is time to end my
competitive career
the labor cup next week in London will
be my final ATP event
I will play more tennis in the future of
course but just not in Grand Slams or on
the tour
this is a Bittersweet decision because I
will miss everything the tour has given
me but at the same time there is so much
to celebrate I consider myself one of
the most fortunate people on earth I was
given a special talent to play tennis
and I did it at the level that I never
imagined for much longer than I ever
thought possible
the last 24 years on tour have been an
incredible Adventure while they
sometimes feel like it went by in 24
hours it has also been so deep and
magical that it seems as if I've already
lived a full lifetime
I've had the immense Fortune to play in
front of you in over 40 different
countries
I have laughed and cried felt Joy and
Pain and most of all I have felt
incredibly alive
well let's get some reaction to this
huge story from tennis broadcaster Craig
Gabriel who joins me now live from
Hamburg Craig are you surprised that
he's decided to call it quits now
yes and no it's a difficult question to
give a definitive answer to because I
think we were all expecting it but at
the same time it still comes as a
surprise and a shock and I think a lot
of people thought that maybe he would
end up if he was going to retire this
year that it would happen in Basel which
is his home tournament but he's decided
to do it at Labor cup I think we could
all see it coming but it still comes as
a shock and a surprise
absolutely he says it it comes as a
shock because I actually remember him at
Wimbledon this year he was there for a
ceremonial reason he said he hoped to be
back there next year so
um what do you think has led him to make
this decision right now and you know why
he hasn't waited a bit longer
it's it's the knee issue all over again
because he started to feel discomfort in
the knee just recently as he was
practicing to be able to play at Laver
cup and hopefully Basel so he says you
know after the last two three years with
these injuries that he's been suffering
and the number of surgeries that he's
been through that his body can't handle
anymore and to go through the pace of
playing major events like the Australian
Open or Wimbledon or the US where you're
playing best of five sets
um it makes it very difficult so as he
was saying he said you know it's not the
end of tennis for him he's still going
to be playing tennis just not at the
majors or on the regular ATP Tour so
what do you think he means by that then
if he's not going to be playing in the
majors or on the tour and where else
would he be playing
well it'll be social stuff I think with
his kids and and just fun things and
then also maybe maybe an exhibition here
or there
um you know in in some time to come when
he feels a little bit more fitter with
his injury issues but when it comes to
the Grind of the regular tour his body
is not being able to stand up to that
and hence the decision it's this has
been a huge year for retirements
starting the year with Ash bhati
retiring as number one Serena Williams
um just recently at the U.S open Angie
Kerber another one that's hanging up the
rackets and now Roger so
um it's been quite a year for for
players ending their careers it
certainly has and Craig you spent a lot
of time covering his career can you just
give us your Fondest Memories
oh goodness saying um you know some of
the private Chats on occasions but some
of the matches just to see how glorious
he was on a tennis court his movement
was like a ballet dancer
um the way he would Glide across the
court the way he would play his
single-handed backhand and and the
Precision that he would play returns
with I think back to these those finals
at Wimbledon against Rafa I mean 0708
and and among the greatest matches ever
played the finally played against Andy
Roddick at Wimbledon the Australian Open
um final that he won to give him his
20th major I mean there's so many
um moments with his career and uh it's
just a really nice guy and uh you know
somebody was always very interested in
what you were doing as well and you
think now this is going to kind of Usher
in this this new era of tennis we've
just had Carlos alcross for example
um just win the US Open uh so yeah are
we now looking at a new era in the sport
oh look it's just so exciting and the
Chinese have a saying that says may you
live in interesting times and that's
what a situation of men's tennis is at
the moment meant the future of men's
tennis is in brilliant hands when you've
got the likes of Yannick sinner Carlos
um Casper root the two finalists
recently
um you know so many exciting players and
then there's that other group of Stefano
sitsapas hopefully Alexander zverev gets
back
um and and you know the competition is
still going to be alive and you've still
got Rafa there you've still got Novak
there but yes you are seeing uh a
gradual changing of the god which is so
thrilling for the sport and such nice
people that are playing at the moment
absolutely lots to look forward to and
as I mentioned previously Federer is
third on the all-time list in terms of
grand slams but for you personally as
somebody who's watched him you know many
times where does he rank for you among
the greats do you think he is the
greatest
I actually do think he's the greatest
um but it's such a difficult uh point to
really be definite about because you're
going through so many eras of the sport
so many changes I mean from equipment
changes to court surfaces to diets to
training and and all those sort of
things so it's very difficult just to
say one player is the greatest of all
time
um because of that I think you can say
they are the greatest they are the
greatest of all time a number of players
has the same sort of point with Serena
Williams I don't think she's the
greatest of all time when you look at
some of the records but she is she
changed the face of women's tennis Roger
was The Benchmark was the bar for men's
tennis
well Craig Gabriel there thank you for
your thoughts we'll let you go because I
can imagine you're going to be a very
busy man today
absolutely